you need me don't be yes sir nobody else
nobody else is still close just need oh
there's no more no just you
I'll let you do the honors man Joe Joe
Joe what's up pants going on going on
boy you been dude how you doing good
family everybody's doing no complaints
now you already know what I'm doing is
Christmas time I'm giving back and I'm
also looking to you to make some of my
Christmas list dreams come true like I
do every year yes sir get no business
let me show you what we created for you
you got for me man I'm excited about it
man I'm excited man oh you got a box
inside of a box I'll let you do the
honors so before I open this up I want
to tell the people what's going on you
know I mean I hit you up you picked up
for me because I guess you win some
we're serving football players like
you're always doing I'm trying to get to
you when I told you that this campaign
going on with these Christmas sweaters
just like I wanted you to just come up
with the most expensive ugliest
Christmas to change sweat there's a lot
of a lot of attitude but it's been over
15 years I've been rocking with my boy
even lacing me with some of the cleanest
ice around and now check out this fancy
is 2 Chainz
Christmas wood right here does it feel
like Christmas you're starting to feel a
lot like you know McKenna's I don't even
know I'm trying to think
[Music]
so join you for real isolated morning
fun they're gold real diamonds well
looky there mom
oh that's oh I didn't know that you were
going to do this oh you got the
snowflakes with the glam on it yes what
the ping ping got ping ping all on the
sweater I fade dancing man that's hard
Joe that's alright bro that's hard bro
that's hard bro for real me you got 14
karat yellow gold right here you got
about 70 carats and diamonds all through
there 70 cares bro so so much how much
is this sweater work man
about ninety thousand we had two days to
think about what we were going to do
like the technical aspects of it how to
put the gold onto the sweater so it
stays on and doesn't fall yeah you don't
want to drop this in the club ain't
nobody leaving the club all right we
have to let them go down make sure it's
the right thickness had to flatten the
gold it took about five straight days of
work on three days hmm
so it's the most ugliest prettiest and
expensive Christmas sweater call the
number at the bottom 1-800 Rich's foot
I'm really I'm really lost to worries
man
this sweaters doing a lot of talking and
I can't even say ugly no more yeah my
one snowflake saying no that's hard man
you did your thing man
any and everybody support me I
appreciate y'all this is this heart Joe
man appreciation man what up what up
you tell me 9500 cake would you pay that
boy sweat but I bought the sweater for
100,000 I sleep in I eat in it I have
sex in it if you do support us a man I
appreciate it
it will be going back to a charitable
contribution because I'm gonna help
somebody out with this other Savoy
minute teaching true